[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
exploring the possibility that potions
professor severus snape
never actually died we see what we
believe to be snape dying in the deathly
hallows
after voldemort thinks that he needs to
kill snape in order to become the true
owner of the elder wand
we of course later find out that snape
died in vain as he was never the true
owner of the elder wand
at all and was unnecessarily killed by
voldemort
however what was always interesting
about voldemort killing snape
was that he didn't do it himself he used
nagini
why doesn't it work for me severus in
the silence harry imagined he could hear
the snake
hissing slightly as it coiled and
uncoiled or was it voldemort's sibilant
sigh lingering on the air my my lord
said snape blankly i do not understand
you
you have performed extraordinary magic
with that wand
no said voldemort i've performed my
usual magic
i am extraordinary but this wand no
it has not revealed the wonders it has
promised i feel no difference between
this one
and the one i procured from olivander
all those years ago
the elder wand cannot serve me properly
severus because i am not its true master
the elder one belongs to the wizard who
killed its last owner you killed albus
dumbledore
while you live severus the elder wand
cannot truly be mine
my lord snape protested raising his wand
it cannot be any other way said
voldemort i must waste the one severus
mast the wand and i master potter at
last
and voldemort swiped the air with the
elder wand it did nothing to snape
before a split second seemed to think he
had been reprieved
but then voldemort's intention became
clear this next cage was rolling through
the air
and before snape could do anything more
than yell it had encased him
head and shoulders and voldemort spoke
in parcel tongue
kill there was a terrible scream harry
saw snape's face
losing the little color it had left it
whitened as his black eyes widened
as the snake's fangs pierced his neck as
he failed to push the enchanted cage off
himself
as his knees gave away and he fell to
the floor nagini
killing snape rather than voldemort
using avada kadavra
which would surely end his life does
actually leave the door open a little
bit
particularly as it's supposedly nagini's
venom that ends up bringing snape to his
inevitable demise
he did not know why he was doing it why
he was approaching the dying man
he did not know what he felt as he saw
snape's white face
and the fingers trying to staunch the
bloody wound at his neck
harry took off the invisibility cloak
and looked down upon the man he hated
whose widening black eyes found harry as
he cried to speak
harry bent over him and snape seized the
front of his robes
and pulled him close a terrible rasping
gurgling noise issued from snape's
throat
take it take it something more than
blood was leaking from snape
silvery blue neither gas nor liquid it
gushed from his mouth in his ears and
his eyes
and harry knew what it was but did not
know what to do
a flask counted from thin air was thrust
into his shaking hand by hermione
harry lifted the silvery substance into
it with his wand
when the flask was full to the brim and
snape looked as though there was no
blood left in him
his grip on harry's robes slackened look
at me
he whispered the green eyes found the
black but after a second
something in the depths of the dark pair
seemed to vanish leaving them fixed
blank and empty the hand-holding harry
thudded to the floor
and snape moved no more the above
passage suggests that snape died
but at the beginning of the next chapter
we should take note of the fact that
harry gets distracted
almost immediately after snape's demise
harry remained kneeling at snape's side
simply staring down at him
until quite suddenly a high cold voice
spoke so close to them
that harry jumped on his feet the flask
gripped tightly
in his hands thinking that voldemort had
re-entered the room
there are a couple of things that
support the fact that snape may not have
actually died
first of all harry didn't really stick
around to make sure that snape
had actually died it looked that way but
this is a magical world after all
and i think that it's definitely within
the realm of possibility for him to have
survived
additionally snape's corpse was never
found or mentioned
after the battle of hogwarts all the
bodies were accounted for
even the bodies of death eaters harry
sees the corpses of people that he knows
and loves
lupin fred etc and provided that harry
knew of snape's sacrifice
it's reasonable to assume that they
would search for his body as well
snape was bitten by nagini and
presumably died from snake's venom
but one glaringly obvious issue with
this is that snape was a potion's master
the likelihood that snape wouldn't know
of or carry an anti-venom is highly
unlikely
particularly as he was playing the
dangerous role of a spy in the wizarding
war
snape was a smart man and he would have
likely been prepared for any eventuality
new guinea biting him included so how
does that explain snape's lifeless body
there's always a possibility that the
venom only paralyzed him and placed him
into a comatose state
there's plenty of snake venom out there
that does just this
and this comatose state could have
easily been confused as snape dying
harry never really examined snape after
he died
so if snape had taken an anti-venom
before being bitten it may have just
taken some time for the effects to kick
in
i don't think that snape bled out either
as he had even invented his own counter
curse
that could stop blood from flowing from
the body vulnerable
another thing that could potentially
support the argument that snape never
died
is the fact that harry never saw him in
the forbidden forest
when harry produces the resurrection
stone he sees the shades of his father
sirius lupin and his mother all of these
people were massively important in
harry's life
they were neither ghost nor truly flesh
he could see that
they resembled most closely the riddle
that had escaped from the diary so long
ago
and he had been memory made nearly solid
less substantial than living bodies
but much more than ghosts they moved
toward him
and on each face there was the same
loving smile
the fact that snape wasn't there could
work either before or
against the argument that he never died
here's why
first it's important to note the stone
shows you your loved ones
and people who are massively important
to you given that at this point
harry was aware of all the sacrifices
that snape had made
you'd expect that he would show up along
with the other shades
snape protected harry for years and even
died with the ultimate goal of saving
him
so you'd expect to see snape wouldn't
you the issue with this
is that snape is just not on the same
level as his parents
sirius and lupin snape made huge
sacrifices for harry
yes but harry wasn't aware of them until
very close at the time
that he presented the stone his feelings
for snape were still settling in
as he'd only recently had a change of
heart about the man who tormented him
for much of his youth additionally the
stone was meant to bring back the people
that harry never got a chance
to say goodbye to and with snape he did
get this opportunity
i know that in the epilogue harry
referenced the snape when he says to
albus severus
you were named for two headmasters of
hogwarts one of them was a slytherin
and he was probably the bravest man i
ever knew and i know that
new sort of suggests that perhaps snape
might have died
but it also might just mean that harry
hadn't seen snape in a very long time
in closing do i think that snape is
alive most likely
not but there is definitely an argument
here for how and why
he could be what do you guys think is
snape still alive
i'm interested to hear what you guys
think let us know down in the comment
section
below until next time you're wizard
[Music]
harry
you